Audiences were hungry for Netflix's new
series on Jeffery Dahmer – but no one
asked what the people involved in the real-life
case would think about the series, until now.
The sheer number of movies and television
series on the subject indicates that people
have a twisted affection for serial killers.
Hollywood has long been cashing in on the
stories of some of humanity's worst people, and
the true crime boom has only fanned the flames.
In the last few years, we've seen two films
about the notorious serial killer Ted Bundy
alone: "Extremely Wicked, Shockingly
Evil, and Vile" and "No Man of God."
However, when it comes to television, it seems no
killer has been as high-profile as Jeffrey Dahmer.
2017's "My Friend Dahmer" looks at the Milwaukee
Monster's coming of age, and the documentary
series "Conversations with a Killer: The Jeffrey
Dahmer Tapes" recently debuted on Netflix.
Most recently, the murderer and sex offender
is the subject of "Dahmer — Monster:
The Jeffrey Dahmer Story." The series has
hit a significant milestone for Netflix,
quickly surpassing 300 million hours
viewed. Still, "The Jeffrey Dahmer
Story" has its share of critics, many of whom
are the relatives of Dahmer's victims. Now,
those families have begun to speak
out about the divisive series.
"The Jeffrey Dahmer story is
so much bigger than just him."
Despite the immense popularity of "Dahmer —
Monster: The Jeffrey Dahmer Story," the series
has received its share of backlash. Some headlines
were in response to a production assistant who
claimed on-set conditions were traumatizing,
while others pushed back against Netflix
initially tagging the series as an "LGBTQ" story.
But most damning has been the reaction from the
victims' families, many of whom have condemned the
series for being retraumatizing and exploitative.
In a piece for Insider, Rita Isbell
— whose brother, Errol Lindsey,
was murdered by Dahmer in 1991 — denounced
Netflix for failing to reach out to her,
even though they recreated her victim's
impact statement in the widely-viewed series.
"I don't ever want to have to see
my mother go through this again."
She said,
"I was never contacted about the show. I
feel like Netflix should've asked if we
mind or how we felt about making it. They
didn't ask me anything. They just did it."
Isbell also added, quote,
"It's sad that they're just making money
off of this tragedy. That's just greed."
Eric Perry, whom the New York Times described
as a relative of the Isbells, agreed, saying,
"It's retraumatizing over and
over again, and for what? How
many movies/shows/documentaries do we need?"
While series co-creator Ryan Murphy has a
reputation for creating violent and dark
series like "American Horror
Story," many believe that the
series' creators should have taken much
more care with this particular story,
taking into consideration the real pain and
suffering of the families of Dahmer's victims.
Eric Wynn, a former performer at Club 219 in
Milwaukee, where Dahmer frequently visited,
also criticized the series' existence in an
interview with the New York Times. He said,
"It couldn't be more wrong, more
ill-timed, and it's a media grab."
For Wynn, who personally knew
some of Dahmer's victims,
the series is especially disappointing
coming from creator Ryan Murphy,
who also created the inclusive, joyful
series "Pose." Wynn, who is Black, said,
"I was so impressed; we finally had representation
that we were involved in. And then he turns around
and does this, somebody who is actually
attacking the Black gay community."
Murphy reportedly set out to tell Dahmer's
story with the victims at the center,
a point which actors on the
show emphasized during media
appearances. Star Evan Peters described
the series to Netflix Queue by saying,
"It's how society and our system failed to
stop him multiple times because of racism
and homophobia. Everybody gets
their side of the story told."
But for at least some of the victims' families,
the series failed to meet that goal. Of Dahmer's
years-long reign of terror over the queer
community in Milwaukee, Wynn said, "That's a scar
on our city." But for some of those closest to
the case, it's a wound that still hasn't healed.